news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
let's go next to um
i want to go to i think we're going to
the uk
now with ian from southampton
ian uh welcome to the program what's on
your mind
uh so i have some uh tactics questions
regarding biden's performance last night
please um
i watched the whole thing it was about 3
a.m to 4 a.m for me so i was a little
bit out of it
uh but i did notice that he actually
just
came out and said that trump was the
worst president of the united states yes
that was a great moment in my mind well
here's the thing
for me the way he delivered that and
actually the way he delivered a number
of the other
insults which i think are really just
adjectives in this case
yes um was in a way that
didn't necessarily seem to be serious it
didn't seem to be the denunciation it
should be it seems very
joe biden this is all you know it's kind
of funny what this trump guy is and
who he thinks he is you know um i don't
totally disagree and by the way i'm
hearing all sorts of discord tweets and
beeps so if you can mute those that
that would be a beautiful thing how
would i do that that i don't know
that i don't know but um my what i was
going to say is i actually
liked the biden laughing because trump
as a narcissist
and trump is an authoritarian he wants
people angry and afraid
and nothing communicates the opposite
then
biden just laughing trump off as an
unserious person so i i don't disagree
with you with the micro which is
when biden said trump's the worst
president ever he didn't really do it in
the serious denunciation way we might
have liked to see
but it was part of just laughing the guy
off and i think trump really didn't like
that
yeah so this is kind of um my next point
is that to me what that signaled
is on some level that trump isn't
necessarily
a threat and trump isn't serious and he
did have that big moment at the end
where he was talking he did the very
serious look to camera get out and vote
which i liked again
um but it's it seems that
the the sort of laughing laughing off at
that bit at least laughing for some of
it is fine and
some of the sillier stuff he said was
fine yeah but i feel that he
he missed the mark with some of the
insults and the denunciations
all right fair point and point well
taken ian i am going to let you go
because the
the the beeps are just uh they're really
nice they're creating a problem for us
but it's a point taken and reasonable
people can can certainly disagree